Please welcome Lizz Winstead Lizz
Winstead is the cocreator and former head
writer of the daily show and
cofounder of Air America radio.
She's the author of live free or die
and her latest project is lady parts
Justice League. Liz, thank you for
joining us for having me. I'm so,
I had made a note to myself when I was
coming up with what to talk about before
we dive into everything. I'll just
ask, look, a nice opening question,
maybe something based on the news
of the day. And then I was like,
that's a terrible idea. That doesn't
sound like a pleasant way to, well,
the news of the day.
It's like the news of the moment.
So I don't know when this goes up.
Yeah.
I haven't looked at other things
that we'll be tackling. Matt.
Yeah. Basically just say garbage,
fire and Lavonne. Yeah. All right.
So with that out of the way,
garbage, fire, garbage partner now,
um, what is lady parts?
Justice League? Well, uh,
it is, we're a, we're a nonprofit,
but that is made up of Comedians,
writers,
graphic designers, shooters, editors,
and it's a bunch of people that decided
there's so much horrible news happening
in the landscape of
reproductive rights and justice.
And when you turn on your television or
you talk to other friends who care about
this, oftentimes they think they
know and they don't know, uh,
they know about one third of
what's actually happening.
And so we wanted to do two things.
We wanted to make videos that expose the
politicians and the laws and just the
Cretins in general who are assaulting
the access to reproductive healthcare.
And then the other cool thing we do,
which is sort of my favorite
thing that we do, is we are a Bam.
That is a combination of kind of like,
let's call it a USO show
and habitats for humanity.
So actually today we are launching,
we're doing a 16 week tour that
we're just announcing today. Um,
we're going to eight for eight weeks.
We're going to 16 cities starting June
2nd in the deep south and the Midwest.
We'll do it.
We'll do a comedy music show and then
we're going to do outreach to clinics.
We're going to like help build
fences, um, do gardening for them,
bring them like food,
take them up or drinks anything to sort
of normalize their work and to sort of
do a emotional reset on what it means
to be a provider. Because I think I had,
I started this,
um,
in 2012 I just did my own little comedy
tour of clinics and when I talked to
providers and maybe the
receptionist or even like a nurse,
they would say to me, thank you
for coming here. No one ever comes.
And that just struck a chord with
me so profoundly than I thought.
I don't really have to
adjust my life at all.
I'm basically just still
doing shows making,
but I'm horning in on a subject that
I care deeply about that I feel like
doesn't get enough attention. So
that's what it is. It's what we do.
That's pretty awesome. Thanks. One of
the things you mentioned is gardening,
and I actually hadn't
heard about this before.
Can you talk a little bit about like,
we know what a fence at an
abortion clinic would help. Do you,
can you talk about your daughter when a
garden at an abortion clinic does? Well,
let me tell you, because it does
many things and it's more than that.
I don't bury the fetuses.
They are contrary to the news from
Breitbart and alternative facts.
Um,
so a lot of times when we,
cause we contact the clinics in advance
to see what they need and they always
say things like, it's like an orphanage.
Sometimes it's like just, you know,
if you had cupcakes or if he
could just come by, you know,
it's like, no, seriously.
So we bring cupcakes or lunch and then
we sort of assessed what's happening.
And so a good example of what we do
is we went to North Carolina, um,
because there's an organization that was
called 40 days for life that was trying
to plan a sneak attack on this clinic.
Well,
we do some infiltrating of websites
and places and found out about this.
So we decided to go down there and
preempt this massive bus that came.
And so protestors,
oftentimes we'll stand on
property anywhere they can
and the clinic doesn't even
see like a whole that could be filled.
So we looked at where the protestors
were standing and realize, you know,
if we just planted a gigantic Holly Bush
and if you know anything about Holly,
it's really prickly that's tall enough,
that is just one space that a protest or
can't stand and scream into the clinic.
So we do that. Um, sometimes
it's like when you build a fence,
you just have to do some
gardening around it.
So it can be strategic planting
or it can be, you know what,
this is a place people go to the doctor.
It should look nice and
it should feel normal.
And so our big thing is to bust
stigma. You know, get rid of the shame.
Let doctors feel like they can live
in the light and have had to have the,
have the staff and people and p patients
that go feel like they're doing what
they are doing,
which is accessing one of a panoply of
medical services that somebody might need
in their lifetime. So making it
normal, making abortion. Great.
Again. What we do. Um,
let's, I'd love to back up and
just look at how you got here.
So we back all the way up.
Um,
it's my understanding that you grew
up in a Catholic home in the Midwest,
so everyone super psyched
about my choices in life. Yeah.
So I did you,
was there some like
grand feminist awakening?
There was a couple grand
feminist awakening.
One was that much to the luck of me,
I'm the youngest of five kids and my
family and my parents are Super Catholic.
Like not like this Pope Catholic like,
cause a couple pumps that go
catholic will popsicle Catholic.
This poll is sort of awesome,
right? I mean, he's kind of like,
I look at this pope and I
think he's kind of like, uh,
a guy who was in a crappy band,
but when I was having an amazing
solo career, so it's like,
and then when they play the old hits,
you're like, shut up with the old days.
It's ain't nobody got time for
your old heads. Um, so it was, uh,
it was one of those things where
there was a couple things. One,
I had never been in,
this is going to just sound horrible
in the context of what we talked about
already. I was never driven to have kids.
It's just never been my thing. Right.
And so even as a little kid,
like I am the person that loved Barbie.
And so it because Barbie had a boyfriend
and she had her own house and a car and
like I didn't care what the boobs
or even that she couldn't stand.
The fact of the matter is, she was
like independent, put her in the car.
There she goes, you know. So I
really liked that in a doll. And I,
and even my mom said, you know, you
never play with the things I give you.
And it was like,
well you gave me like a baby doll and
then you gave me an iron and then you gave
me an ironing board and
then he gave me a stove.
And it's like basically everything that
you saw at night over you gave to me as
like a toy. It's like, where's the
inflatable drunk? Have a husband toy cars,
why don't we just round
this whole life out? Um,
and so I needed to make money as a kid,
you know,
for candy and lip gloss or whatever we
were raising money for at that time.
And I saw all the boys being
ultra boys, right. And I was like,
well that's a way to make money.
They were like raking it in serving
at weddings and funerals, you know,
apparently you didn't get paid for
like the, the Sunday mass thing.
So when I went to the priest and I said,
I want to be an ultra boy,
the priest freaked out and said,
pulled out of his ass. Literally.
He goes, well, you can't
because, and I could see,
you know how adults going like this when
they're like done having to say like,
it was like doing that. And he was like,
well, you know, it's called alter boy.
So obviously I was like, well,
and I wasn't trying to be a jerk.
I was just trying to get to
make money at the weddings.
That's what I wanted to do.
So I said, well, you know,
you could call me an altar girl.
And then he was like, well, uh,
you know, you should, you should write the
archbishop just passing the buck. Right?
So I got a petition and
I wrote the archbishop.
And like not long after I wrote
the Archbishop, unfortunately, uh,
during length,
archbishop had too much to drink and
deploy out into the wall of a seven 11.
So the archbishop had his own problems
to deal with and wasn't concerned about
letting me be an ultra by.
But at that point I just was like,
I had this little case of like,
I don't get it.
I don't get why I'm a girl and I
can't be an altar boy. This is dumb.
And so there was just instances in,
in life in general where if there was
a clear explanation like don't climb a
tree barefoot cause that's
gonna cut your feet.
I'm like oh that seems like
good advice from an adult.
But if there was no real explanation,
I was just mad.
And because I was a curious kid and so
there was just a series of that shit that
started happening. And then
somebody said, you know,
I haven't got cynical and then
I would be a little snarky.
And then somebody said
he should try stand up.
When I was in college and I thought,
and this was a part that really got me
and I looked at the landscape of standups
and two,
there was women doing it.
There was like Joan Rivers and
there was like Phyllis Diller.
But I didn't see myself. I was
like a punk rock, 23 year old kid.
And I didn't see, I didn't see my
world coming out of anybody's mouths.
And then I saw George Carlin.
And so it took a dude to convince
me that I could do stand up,
which was a problem,
like the bag that I did not see myself.
And now it's so cool to see all of
these really amazing women doing it.
But yeah, so I started out, you know,
just doing it and I would do like,
I wasn't particularly political at the
time, you know, I would have jokes like,
um, if you ever play monopoly with
bald guys, they always pick the hat,
you know, stupid that took,
doesn't even deserve that much laughter.
But I'm not even kidding.
That was really nice of you to do that.
You know,
I saw and then I would talk about gender
and equity or you know, dating. But um,
he really wasn't, if I cared about
politics, I was very, I like,
I read about it and I knew about it,
but I didn't put, bring into stage. Um,
and then I guess if there
was like true comedy,
how did it change everything? It would
have to be, oh my God, I can swear here.
Right. And stuff. You have been, oh, I,
I should have asked my 10 minutes ago.
Um,
I had moved to New York in 1991 and
somebody sent me up on a blind date.
Um, do you remember those? There was,
it happened like they don't exist now
cause you just hook up with people you
regret later on your phone. Um, but
there was a thing and it was like,
it never was, I've got a person
for you. Actually you don't.
But I would go cause I'm from the
Midwest and when someone says, you know,
I have a person very, you're like, all
right, well that's nice. I'll go to that.
Cause you mean,
right.
So the guy shows up at my house and,
and you know, like what's
the plan? I'm like,
well maybe do you want
to go see La Dolce Vita?
I've never seen it on a big screen.
And he looks at me and he's like,
it was the Lou in black and
white, you know, like, oh man.
And if that wasn't bad enough,
he is wearing a Yankees hat
and a Yankee satin jacket.
And I have a theory about guys that were
more than one piece of sports clothing
at the same time. And that is
that they won't go down on you.
I believe this is a proven thing.
So I'm like,
this is like a double whammy of,
but I'm going to do it cause I'm
from the Midwest and I'm nice.
So we go to the movie and then the guy,
this is going somewhere, people the story,
I swear to God and I feel
like she is probably not. Um,
and the guy keeps falling asleep and
then the rubbing his satin jacket up and
down my arm and I'm just like eating my
popcorn and like getting more and more
rageful to the point where I was like,
like fighting internally. My like I'm
real nice and I fucking hate this guy.
So finally I just took my greasy hands
and I just like purposely hit his jacket
to wake him up.
And then I felt horribly.
I just felt horrible that I actually
wrecked his jacket on purpose. And then,
so I had to make up for it by saying,
wake up, let's go have a drink,
continuing this new.
So we go to a bar that he knew about
because he watched sports there.
Um,
but on this night there was no sports
on because it was the night of the first
Gulf War and if you'll remember you
won't cause you probably weren't born.
But um,
it was the first time that
America watched a war,
like unfold in their living rooms live
and they had replaced like the regular
anchors on CNN with like handsome people.
And there was that green light
and people were very long ball.
I'm Dirk sturdy on the roof and the bombs.
And it was like,
I just watched it and I wasn't
trying to wax philosophical.
I was just taking it in thinking are
they reporting on a war or trying to sell
me a war?
And about two minutes later the date
was like, this is really awesome.
And I was like,
this is a fucking problem.
And so I just sort of started from that
moment on like paying more attention to
the media, seeing the information
that like I was getting,
seeing what kind of like are they just
reporting the press releases from the
White House? Like what can I talk
about? What can I not, you know?
And so my comedy acts or to changing
dramatically. Talking a lot about, um,
not only America's role in the world,
politics in general,
but also the media's role
in how all that played out.
And when I realized as we started getting
ourselves into these big manipulative
wars that the media was as complicit
as any, I mean literally when,
when your network is reporting on
the news and doing reports about the
negotiations of whether or
not we're going to go to war.
And then when they go to commercial,
there's a giant graphic that says
countdown to the war. You're like, um,
I'm going to go shit. Or do you
know something? I don't know.
Because you are literally have a theme
song and a graphic that says we're
counting down to the war,
not work.
Negotiating to see if
we're going to go to war.
So I did a couple of one
woman shows and then, um,
I was like trying to figure out what
I was going to do next and will,
I worked on Jon Stewart's first talk
show as a producer and when that got
canceled,
um,
a small group of that team was asked
by our executives who had moved over to
comedy central if we wanted to launch
a show that responded to the world.
And I was like, oh my
God, are you kidding me?
I am like a person who can barely type
and I've never run any show and all I do
is spout off my mouth. But
yes, it's kind of my dream.
And so the daily show was born,
um,
and created by a whole bunch of
people who had a lot of passion for,
um,
exposing hypocrisy and being
funny and well, you know,
fair. It is. I'm here for
20 years. It did good.
Yeah.
Um,
some of the,
I'm curious about in your
work before the daily show,
the daily show and after it's,
you know, you said that they,
they wanted you guys to create a
show that was responding to the news,
the news. Yeah. And so you use comedy
to talk about politics and world events,
but in the daily show,
in your other work,
it's also using politics and world
events as the fodder for comedy.
Yeah. And also as a potter for
the media, you know, I can,
it can't be stressed enough how much the
media has played a role through all of
this. You know, how much cable news
and as it bloated out more, um,
has been complicit in
all of it. So yes. Um,
I think the problem that I faced is, you
know, after we launched the daily show,
um,
and then I left and I went on
to do some other smaller shows.
I did one on oxygen that was like
actually a really funny show that was six
episodes. That was like the daily
show meets cold bear mates. Um, Kathy,
Liam, who, whatever those women are living
here. It was like that kind of format.
Um, and then we launched Air
America radio. Yeah. And, um,
and even that,
as,
as I'm out there as it was,
or as much freedom as we had,
should I say,
it was still a part of an entity
that was a corporate entity. And,
and the bottom line is, and all of these
projects, I say this a lot, but it's true.
I felt a lot like an anger fluffer.
Like I've just got people riled up,
but it wasn't my job to have a call to
action so that can be funny and give
people information and they're like,
what do I do? Not? And I'm like, no,
I'm just a comedian.
I'm just the writer.
I wanted to be able to give people
a place to channel the energy.
And so that's why,
um,
I wrote a book and then
after I wrote the book, um,
I decided that I really wanted to take
all of the things I care about, comedy,
social justice,
making a difference through comedy and
actually then hitting the ground and
doing tangible work.
Um,
and the only way to do
that was to start a thing.
That's how I started this thing.
And so that brings us to this, this
thing is perfect thing here. Yeah.
Cause something I wonder about with the,
the lack of call to actions is, you know,
you'll see on Twitter and social media
nowadays, like people saying like,
look at this, this is happening. This
is not normal. Don't be complacent.
And I'm like, I'm not, what do
I, what do I do? So what sort of,
how are you moving from just raising
people's awareness of what's going on to
actually giving them tools or helping
them figure out what they can do?
Well,
I think one of the things that's
important for me is a figuring out how,
when, when you sign up to
volunteer for us, for example, uh,
we ask you how much time you have
to give, what your skill set is. Um,
and then we can make that work. Also.
Like for example, in the women's March,
it's, we had, we had an activist fair
that we sponsored where we had 15 tables.
It was right off the march path.
At a hotel called the UN hotel.
We did it here in New York cause I
thought like, I don't want to go to DC.
I want to stay here because a lot of
the policies that people are going to be
affected by those people live here. You
know, we have strong immigrant population,
strong undocumented population,
women, you know, all of it. Um,
and so we had 15 different
organizations representing 15 different,
um,
ways that you could participate,
whether it was environmental and racial
justice, you know, whatever it was. Um,
and sort of our rule was your group has
to be able to let people like get in
there and do some work, you know, not
just sign up and not just give us money.
Like, because I think that's important.
And so what we, what we do is,
for example,
if you wanted to volunteer with us,
there's a myriad of things you
could do. You can, um, we signed,
we send postcards to clinics,
um, throughout the year.
And then we have four times a year.
We have orchestrated postcode programs
where I'm sending them love really makes
all the difference in the world. So, you
know, that's a simple thing we can do.
We help legislative do like everybody else
does where you can sign this petition.
Um, for example, a, this is crazy.
So we've worked with a clinic in Ohio.
We went to Ohio to help out during
the Republican convention because um,
part of the activities for the RNC was to
go protest to clinic. They had, I mean,
insane. So this clinic that we
have befriended and now work with,
someone stole their fence.
A psychotic person had been like chipping
away at the fence and just stole their
fence. They came to work in their
fence was gone. So we were able to, um,
do a Facebook live event
where we went on and we said,
this clinic had their fence stolen.
They need $10,000 to do it.
Here's the origin story. We put the
origin story out, we tell the thing,
and the clinics said, you guys just
raised us to mine offense in five hours.
So, um, we're, when we pay attention to
the needs of each of these places, uh,
we can specifically tailor, uh,
if, if we need graphic design work,
if a clinic graphic design work
for something they're doing. Um,
if you want to help us with meals, I
mean, this tour that we're going on,
we're launching this tour today,
you know,
it's like weird launching a fundraiser
with it because we need a van.
We're taking 11 bodies to go and grow
community in 16 different cities where our
clinic is desperately needing support
that will last long after we show up.
So,
um,
one of the things that's really kind of
cool is we created a system where we'll
do a comedy music shown a town.
We have a talk back with the provider
and maybe somebody who runs an escort
program or somebody who runs that
abortion fund in that state. Um,
after they laugh and hear music,
they'll hear a Q and a that's like this.
They'll be the last questions and they
can sign up to help the clinic out.
So does that mean you bring
cupcakes four times a year?
Does that mean you help them with hot
breakfast on the Saturday morning when
there's a lot of clinics, does that
mean you sign up to escort yourself?
Does that mean that you get together
and then you can reach out to us?
Um, and say we're trying to figure out
a creative action. Can you help us?
And we're like, sure. You know,
we've helped people with like every
other hospital gowns and go sit here and
state legislatures office and just wait
for your pap smear and then just sit
there and wait and when they come out
and see what he's doing and we're like,
well we're her for pap smears since
you absolutely know how my body works,
I'd like you to actually give
me a pap smear. Um, and so,
you know,
helping people get creative with
their local actions is really great.
And so we are constantly
looking for, um, you know,
people who can fill our
creative pots so that, you know,
cause a lot of plates
are spinning at once.
So if we're trying to help out Indiana,
somebody says I'm creative and like,
great, there's a thing in Ohio, you know,
you can really help us do this
thing or whatever it is. So yeah.
Yeah. The, the specificity in the
concrete action there is amazing.
Before I move on to my next question,
we're going to be opening it up
for audience questions in a minute.
So if you want to ask a question,
just go line up behind one
of those microphones so
that we know that you have a
question. We'll get to that in
one second. Um, but, but first,
in addition to these very specific
local on the ground efforts,
you're also doing a lot online
through social media, through video.
Can you talk a little bit about that?
Yeah.
And maybe we should show one of our
videos. So what a fantastic segue.
What a fantastic segway. So we, um,
one of the greatest joys is
to dispel myths in a way that
people really latch onto.
One of the greatest myths in
reproductive health care is that plan B,
an Iud or abortions.
There was a supreme court case called
Hobby Lobby where this Christian Craft
store, I don't even know
what that means. Um,
decided that um,
they didn't want to disperse birth
control if the birth control was promoting
abortion and they listed plan beyond
their list and it's like plan B does not
only does not perform or
more promote abortion,
it stops an egg from actually leaving
the egg holder scientific term,
um,
in the first place.
So in order to like lay the shit down ones
all, we were like, let's make a video.
So we decided to make a cartoon and we
got led to Loria from orange is the new
black to be the voice of Plan
B and we'll just roll the,
we'll roll the video,
you'll learn a little something.
Sorry man. I have to get another
cashier to sell you plan B.
Why? Because Plan B causes abortion and
I don't have to sell it to you because of
abortion goes against my
religious beliefs. Wait,
it's not an abortion and double wait.
A cashier can demand the birthday.
You are correct ma'am. That is
actually the law and I don't like it.
Listen Up,
Mr. Cashier,
just out of birth control pill,
no matter what they say on Capitol Hill,
well his wrong,
wrong stowaway then
strong,
strong lot do is blog where
I can see which day Liz,
what scientists say.
So at the end of the day you can chew,
drop some fans,
tale world hobble feel dosh
pill preventing unwanted
pregnancy seems so helpful.
How'd you get so many family?
Well a lot of folks like this fella got
together and decided that I caused some
portions but I don't.
I stopped population for happening.
Preventing verbalization
and pregnancy are nice.
Egg isn't a pregnancy APP
or an egg is fertilize.
It takes 72 whole hours for the egg to
make its way to the uterus and Plensa.
That is a pregnancy.
My job is to stop the aid for
ever traveling to below via town,
preventing that pregnancy.
So life doesn't begin at conception
when life begins.
Is it opinion when pregnancy
begins is a scientific back?
Are you getting it yet?
Well think of it like a football game.
The quarterback drops back and tosses
to the receiver at the 20 yard line,
happens a second to the receiver, catches
the ball. Now we all know the rules.
The fertilized eggs still needs to make
it an event before it's a touchdown
bought. If there is no ball
to catch, there can never be,
say, say pregnancy doesn't
happen until their touchdown.
So my job is the block back
such down rope happening.
Wow.
When be you're like the Deion
Sanders isn't preventing pregnancy.
Actually Deion Sanders wishes
he was the plan via football.
Well,
I hope that cleared things up,
but just in case it fits the bill.
A helpful birth control pill no matter
what their sale. Gamble a little hill.
So now you know my truth.
I'm all about prevention.
If you condoms break
Johnny,
take a stand a day.
Hope that you will drop
some fans the world bill.
Wow.
Science is fun.
You prevent more abortions
than anyone I know.
I'd be happy to sell you to customers.
That's right.
Prevention's My jab by now.
Wait pill I ever seen again.
Well let me put it to you this way,
kid.
I'm always here if you need
me and I'm really safe.
So you don't even need a prescription,
even if you're a teenager. Yes.
Even if you're a teenager.
Oh, and just one more thing.
I know I'm awesome,
but please always use a condom.
Join me and take the stand
PJ on shuts down the big bats around
birth control and abortion every damn day.
Join us and not spread the truth.
Did you learn something?
It was really important
for us to make that video,
especially with Neil Gorsuch
who is as you know, um, uh,
in line to possibly be the next Supreme
Court justice and he's somebody who
ruled in the lower court, um, for hobby
lobby agreeing with the fake science that,
you know, so we put it out and it's
also for me really important, um,
the line about teenagers,
you know,
it's good to make videos sometimes that
kids can pass around to their friends
and they can know that I can
go get that if I'm a teen and,
and my condom broke that I, I
can, I can go test that out.
Cause I think a lot of times
we don't let our teens,
we deny sexuality of teens and
especially teen girls so much.
And I think it's important to um,
be living in the world where there's
not abstinence and Unicorns in the one
where there's actually sex and
sometimes um, unintended pregnancy.
And so let's like be real and
help people out. So yeah. Yeah.
And I think one of the,
the great things about that video is
the football shooting as from the penis.
Really good.
One of the other great things in addition,
because there are many bids,
but that's actually my point that like
it has that information for teens where
it's like, hey teens, you can
go get this over the counter.
And it also has information for people
who are already thinking and arguing
about this.
Like the something I haven't heard before
is the distinction between when does
life begin versus pregnancy
begin because anyone can say,
well, I think life starts here.
I think it starts there, right?
That's life. Is that a person? You know
what I mean? Like when, when life begins,
literally is this subjective
and life begins at conception.
That is not a scientific term. It's a Ma.
I mean that is, that's a religious term.
No fertilization is conception. And
so it still needs that, you know,
and as we show this video, if you
just figured that out now don't worry.
Most people are like, I had no idea. It's
like, it's okay. A lot of people didn't.
In fact we thought plan B stopped
an implantation from happening,
but it turns out that's not what it does.
So there's like misnomers around that,
um,
as well.
So we wanted to make sure that people
knew that it stops the egg from actually
leaving the Fallopian tube
in the first place. So, um,
it was approved because they thought
it might have stopped implantation.
And here's what's crazy. The website of
Plan B's says that and it's not right.
So we consulted with a team of physicians
to actually make sure it was right.
So I'm like, so the
football thing, is it cool?
It's like it gets shot out of the thing
and they're like, yeah, it's fine.
So it was having them write,
help us write it into plain,
into medical texts and then having
us translated into Fallopian tonal,
southern ship. Um, it was kinda fun.
Yeah. Well, cause in a lot of them
ways,
the antiabortion movement
has really controlled the
rhetoric of how we talk, talk
about 310% and that can
be incredibly damaging,
incredibly shaming.
And you know,
it's like things that are
very good friends we'll say
are sometimes like I'm in
the larger scale. It can make
people wonder when they say like,
well no one's for abortion. You know what,
except for people who need an abortion,
you know, like I say, often there aren't
a good abortions thrown about abortion.
So it's just the abortion that you need.
And I think that we need to bear that
in mind as somebody who's going through
that choice to, to, uh, to
terminate a pregnancy that, um,
lobbing judgment or saying things like,
um,
that I'm pro choice. I'm not pro
abortion. Um, well, you know,
why is it that you say that?
Um,
by saying that it sounds like abortion
is a dirty thing that has to happen when
if one in three women statistically will
have an abortion in her reproductive
lifetime.
It sounds to me like that's a piece of
medical care that a lot of people are
going to meet. And so for us to put
a caveat or a shaming space on that,
um,
based on the assault of
disinformation medically,
um, we need to examine that
as people are advocates for,
um,
you know,
full autonomy and if you believe that
women's rights are human rights, um,
one of the first rights that we should
all be defending is how and if and when,
um, you want to have kids and make sure
you have full autonomy over your body.
I believe
I just entirely lost my train of thought
because you're thinking about that
penis shooting off that football and
very distracting. I know. That's true.
Um,
one,
one question.
What's something that's been in the news
lately among all the many garbage fires?
Yeah. And especially in the aftermath of
the election is the question of whether
abortion rights and reproductive
freedom should be, um,
a non negotiable issue
in the Democratic Party.
The left if it's, if you can be, you know,
on the left and not
pro choice. I, I mean I'm going to
ask what are your thoughts on that?
I think I know what your thoughts,
I'd love to hear you talking about
wrote a massive piece. There was an
article in the New York Times, um,
uh,
that just was in the New York Times
where a woman wrote that there was Ailey,
it was alienating in the women's movement.
If you are not an
abortion rights advocate.
And what I say to that is
simple, uh, you can totally be,
uh, somebody who has personal
feelings about abortion.
The bottom line is we live in a secular
society where abortion is safer than
having your teeth pulled.
And if you are going to advocate against
a procedure that is going to literally
clear a path for someone to
pursue their own destiny, the no,
that is problematic for me. And that is
problematic for a movement as a whole.
If you say you are a woman's right
advocate or personal, the uterus advocate,
that means that you have to actually
put your feelings aside because your
feelings are your personal feelings.
And when you search your
soul nor searching your
soul for yourself, I do not.
You need you to search your soul and
tell me you've come up with a solution
medically for what I need to do.
That is wrong.
And that is not being a feminist and
that's not part of the feminist moment.
This shouldn't be. Yeah. So
that's how I feel about. Do you,
do you think that you're
right in the comments now,
do you think that um,
opposition to abortion primarily comes
from a religious place or is there
something else cultural or psychological
because people will give politicians
and people who were antiabortion we'll
give lots of reasons. It's usually
religious, I think. Well,
I think when you hear things like
life begins at conception, um, again,
that's a religious thing. Yeah. I mean,
almost all the time it's religious.
And the thing that is,
is it goes back to what you said
of the people who are antiabortion,
who has driven the narrative
to places where, um,
we just let things go.
Junk science,
there's like abortion causes breast
cancer proven it doesn't by every medical
establishment that you can find that
it causes, um, mental illness, again,
not proven in any way, shape
or form. Um, sterility,
no people have multiple abortions,
therefore not true. So, um,
those things just lay there.
And on top of that,
we have states where Indiana prime
example, when Mike Pence was governor,
he defunded planned
parenthood on a state level.
Those planned parenthood's went under.
He gave that $4 million every year that
went to planned parenthood to something
called crisis pregnancy centers.
If you're not aware of what they are,
they're unregulated clinics opened
up by religious people who um,
anybody can wander in as somebody dressed
up in a lab coat who could probably
just work at the Macy's,
Lancome counter to, um,
gives people this information,
we'll give them an ultrasound that is,
um, they might fudge how long, how far
along they are. They may say, yeah,
we'll help you with diapers and cribs.
Just keep coming back.
And then when they're
past the age of being, uh,
the gestational age to have an abortion,
all of a sudden they disappear.
They won't give the person anything.
They're horrible. And so in the,
in the course of funding
those unregulated centers, um,
people are being denied care.
And also in the case of Indiana,
they had this outbreak of HIV,
87 cases of HIV in this county in Indiana.
And the planned parenthood clinic used
to be somebody that would treat sanction
sexually transmitted diseases,
how I'm help people with HIV.
And there was no planned parenthood.
So they actually had to do pop up clinics
when they had a system in place just
because of this. So, um, I think that
those things are, for the most part,
we see it's a religious
argument because the medical,
every single piece of medicine around
the issue of abortion bears out to it
being one of the safest things,
one of the [inaudible] not preventing
you from choosing to have a family in the
future.
So when they start placing these caveats,
especially when it's waiting
periods and things like that,
and they say it's all for the woman's,
um, you know, just to make sure, um,
when you start laying things down,
like we need women to wait, um,
because we're not sure she's
made the right decision.
When that becomes part of the norm in
our society that w if anybody's ever had
the fear of being pregnant and didn't
want to be, or actually ha has been,
you know, from the second you
might think that you're pregnant,
you're thinking about it constantly.
Everything about what that pregnancy
means to your life is thought through over
and over again.
So to require extra time is society saying
we're not really sure we trust women
would make decisions and that goes
out of the abortion rema and goes into
spring, really trust women
to run our company. You know,
should we really trust women
to be president? You know,
I mean, so I think those things
are really telling and um,
things that we should fight against.
While they might seem like it's for the
women, it's not, it's for the control.
Yeah. Um, last call for
questions from the audience,
but in,
in lieu of that, something
I want to ask is, um,
on the lady parts Justice League website,
you have a video page with a video
for every state in the country.
A little and lady parts justice page.
Not The league page.
We have two organizations.
One is political, political,
political. Yeah. Gotcha. Um,
it's sort of like planned parenthood
and planned parenthood action. Yes.
One deals with healthcare outreach,
education,
still swearing and being fun.
That pill video was outreach education.
And then we have lady parts justice,
which is yes.
Has a video for every state and you
can go there and learn about the Po.
We call up politicians by nature. Oh okay.
So that different things. Political yes.
One, yes. Informational.
Educational. Yes. Yes.
So our big tour is through the
Lady Parts Justice League. Gotcha.
Cause we can hit the road, do outreach,
roll up her sleeves, do it. Yeah.
Go to the lay purchased league
website. Yes. Donate to the tour.
It's awesome.
Let's see where we are. Come
visit us. We're at 16 cities.
You probably live in one of them.
Something I wanted to ask for the people
in the audience here who are in New
York, we usually think of in New
York we've got things pretty good,
nice blue state.
But what the challenge both,
what should people be aware of here
in New York state? Funnily enough,
we have not yet
changed our abortion laws since 1970.
We have pre Roe v Wade abortion laws in
our state and while it feels like it's
blue and it's great here and in the
city, um, abortion access is pretty,
uh, accessible. Uh, if you
live in another place around,
if you live in rural New York,
it's really hard for you to access
any kind of care. Um, it's uh,
abortion laws were set in the criminal
code. So if, uh, if you have an a,
if you have a fetal anomaly
that oftentimes when you
hear about those big scary,
they try to scare you with like, um, late
term abortion and why people have them.
And in 99% of those are because things
don't happen gestationally in pregnancy,
sometimes until the final
trimester of that pregnancy.
And so really horrible life
threatening to the woman.
The fetus won't live outside of the
womb. A lot of bad stuff happens. And so,
um, sometimes you won't even know
those things, right? In New York,
if you hit 24 weeks and discover that,
um,
the fetus will, could cause
you, death could die itself. Um,
you can't an abortion.
There is no life of the mother life of
the fetus exception. After 24 weeks,
you have to leave the state.
So yeah.
So that's like a lot of the talent that's
in place now and they're fighting for,
they're fighting to change that
law right now. Um, but we have, uh,
a kind of conservative, um, you know,
a lot of conservatives in Albany,
some of them are Democrats
who were anti choice. Um,
so they won't update
these simple, simple, um,
laws that could be fixed and,
you know,
add logical exceptions so
people don't die. Seems smarter,
just not dying,
not dying.
Seems like living seems like
a good alternative to not
dying. I don't know. Um,
for that part. Yeah. Yeah.
All right. Well, Liz,
thank you. Thank you so much. Thank you.
It was really great. Thanks for having me.
Thank you.